no generation of kids in history has
ever faced anything like this never has
there been this concerted coordinated
far-reaching effort to deprive them of
that which is most basic
themselves and that's why we're here
today because we're not going to sit in
silence while our kids while any kids
are ripped to shreds by these damned
vultures these monsters
this rally means the future of the
education system for our children i have
four school-aged children in loudoun
county the things that are going on with
the loudoun county school board are
things that are criminal and shouldn't
be allowed it's unconscionable teaching
is a critical race theory that teach
that the white race is inherently evil
is inherently racist why in the world
would we teach that an entire race is
evil when the entire goal since the
civil rights act was to eliminate the
color barriers within our country there
are thousands of members that are so
against this and thousands more that are
quiet about the issue i feel like in
this area in particular there's enough
people that just go along with it and
they might start paying attention to a
little bit of disruption we are parents
who care about our children and not just
our own children but all children and
we're not going to abandon them to be
brainwashed and abused by a morally and
intellectually corrupted education
system
if you're on the other side of this if
you're in the opposition and that scares
you
then i'm glad that it does if we have
you worried then good you should be
because we're not going away that's not
going to happen
i want parents to have their rights
given back to them to have a voice with
their children this is a example of when
people are standing up and not not just
sitting down and listening to what
they're saying oh whatever it's not a
problem it's not not a big deal and then
we end up with things like this where we
have men in the women's bathrooms men
and women's sports teams it can't
continue and loudon county is where we
need to we need to start this you know
they turn the whole world upside down
and demand that we all pretend that the
ceiling is the floor and the floor is
the ceiling and we're not going to do
that we can't the days of polite
cooperation with evil and falsehood are
over now they're completely over
i would love to see them define what is
a woman consider the fact that none of
the people on the school board who are
making policies related to gender can
even tell you exactly what a woman is
they cannot define what a woman is
they're saying whoever identifies it
means nothing now they can't even define
words that my four-year-old could define
because he doesn't go to loudoun county
schools
just people caring about people and not
caring about feelings
there is no compassion without truth you
can't love a person by leaving them to
stew in their own delusions and if i
surrender the truth and i have
surrendered the only thing worth
fighting for
yes we should be compassionate towards
people but
humans are the goal not some fantasy
thought education divorce from truth is
not education at all it is many other
things it's brainwashing it's
conditioning it's intellectual abuse
it's indoctrination
but it's not education by imposing these
unrealities these falsehoods these
untruths the loudoun county school board
has fundamentally destroyed the very
education it's supposed to be
facilitated having matt walsh here to
just give his support it's super great
because he generally gives an unbiased
opinion and he's open to dialogue with
those he disagrees with and it's
important to have someone like that at
the rally so i think that means a lot
because it definitely gets the word out
i know he has over half a million
followers on twitter so it helps spread
awareness and spread the word for people
to also understand what's going on in
our school system this year's history in
the making matt walsh is bringing a lot
of people over here getting people
finally brave enough to stand and say no
more to what the school board is doing
to our children's futures i appreciate
matt coming out and i'm glad that he's a
new resident of loudoun county as i've
heard that does mean a lot because
this is something that should gain
national attention i'm so glad he's a
resident of our county and lives in
virginia like he has for at least a day
i want the people on the other side of
this to understand this
your old tricks are not going to work
you could call us hateful and you're
right about that we are we hate
what you are doing to kids that's right
we hate your attack on truth
and on science and on moral decency we
hate that too and you could call us
intolerant and that's also true because
we're not going to tolerate it anymore
who's your favorite daily wire host oh
my goodness i'm going to go with matt
walsh came for ben stayed from that
definitely matt walsh well of course
it's matt walsh because he's a loudoun
county resident and he's here
benjamin
this is the line in the sand that we
have drawn we're not gonna surrender our
kids
to this darkness we're not gonna do it
we're not gonna give up on truth not now
not ever
thank you all i appreciate it thank you
god bless
[Applause]
you so much
[Music]